in new york city right now the city
council is voting soon on a measure that
would allow non-citizens to vote in
local elections this has of course major
implications in the ongoing fight for
election integrity new york city
republicans are already vowing legal
challenges if this is in fact passed and
most likely it will democrats hope that
other cities will follow suit we'll keep
you posted on that meanwhile los angeles
is on the edge as crime continues to
soar there take a listen to lapd
detective jamie mcbride earlier this
week
we're wondering how many times does
somebody have to be arrested here in la
before they stay in jail
it's sad to say but it's almost safer to
hang out with alec baldwin on a movie
set than to go shopping in los angeles
right now that's how crazy it is it is
so violent we're telling people don't
visit because we don't think we can keep
you safe right now
so it's so bad police are warning people
to stay away
from los angeles and joining us now is
the host of the reuben report dave rubin
his next book don't burn this country
comes out in april and dave i think you
need to speed it up uh because we're
getting pretty close to that point
unfortunately but great to see you as
always john i was trying to be cheeky
with that title and yet here we are
don't loot this country i guess i could
have said that by the way i always like
to tell your chiron guys if they want to
put under my name here depressingly in
los angeles that would be just fine
hearing a story like that
i know i'm glad i got to come see you
when i did for your birthday a couple
months ago it was like a little bloom of
freedom in california for a brief second
uh when gavin newsom was up for a recall
election and then of course he won and
now it's regressed uh back to i think
it's i don't know i i think we've lost
california uh dave but uh let's move on
because i don't know if you saw this or
not but uh
we caught the attention of the daily
beast this week for a segment we did
monday here's the story newsmax host
wonders if the uh
patriot front's dc march was
orchestrated by the feds now to be clear
that's not what i was doing i was just
pointing out that the fbi has a bit of a
reputation problem but let's go back to
the article here and another quote of me
bachmann said he wasn't outright
declaring the feds were behind the white
supremacist march again i'm not doing
that i just said that a lot of people
are raising that issue and the daily
beast to their credit cited a tweet from
arizona state senator wendy rogers she
called the group fake she also cited a
tweet
from dinesh d'souza who made some pretty
good points i think about
uh some issues you might pick up with
this group here dinesh desousa has 1.8
million twitter followers
and the article goes back and they quote
me here again dave
this is what i said i'm not saying that
the feds are behind this march this
weekend but just for the sake
again people are raising this issue
dave and the issue is that you know the
fbi
needs some need to do some explaining i
think uh what what dinesh asked in his
tweet i think brings some
pretty
valid points he says it looks fake why
are their faces covered is it because
they are fbi agents posing as right-wing
extremists where are the media
interviews and this is the thing that i
think is important so we can see and
hear directly from this group
you know why aren't they talking to the
press they went to the
national mall you think they want the
attention
well first off john you know you've
truly made it when you're quoting
yourself on your own show pretty good
john bachman a good day for you look
daily beasts let me just say something
about daily beasts first because i have
no doubt that they're watching this
right now it is an absolute trash rag
that nobody clicks on except when they
run hit pieces or they lie about people
or they lie about what people said so
that that gets them clicks they're like
really in some ways they're worse than
buzzfeed they're worse than huffpo
they're just they're just truly trash as
to the point of all of this the the
substance of this of course it's
possible that these were feds where is
this group's twitter account where is
their facebook feed where is their
gab account or other sort of scary
right-wing white supremacist thing that
these people all have why do they all
sort of look the same why couldn't
anyone speak to the media why were all
their faces covered up i mean generally
these people that are always told you
know we're told they're right-wing they
next they're not big mask people yet all
these people had masks on uh they all
physically sort of look the same i mean
they all look sort of fit and in their
20s and 30s and 40s i mean we're allowed
to ask these questions i mean after two
years of covet and masks and
mandates and vaccines and everything
else like we're all entitled to be a
little bit kind of conspiracy
theory-minded at this point so you
absolutely did nothing wrong we're
allowed to ask oh and by the way to your
broader point we know that the fbi has
been up to some shady stuff over the
last couple of years with false flag
operations planning to kidnap gretchen
whitmer and a whole bunch of other stuff
i mentioned that as well that day and
you know after we did our segment joe
rogan also talked about that he raised
some of the same issues that you did
and like yourself he has a pretty big
megaphone too in the world of digital
media here is joe rogan
there has never been
a thing that i've ever seen where almost
immediately i was like those are feds
uh oh did this happen i i immediately
like that's fake like my immediate
feeling i looked at them first of all
these guys are too slim
i'm looking at these guys they're all in
shape
they're all thin
they're they're they're uniformly
marching with flags i mean there's no
way these idiots would be this organized
but if you look at these people walking
down the street with their masks on all
dressed in black all wearing like
essentially a uniform all holding the
same size american
it flag of looked like a color guard to
me dave but you know again and i'm not
the one i think the daily beast or
anybody else should be worried about
why didn't they say anything about
anything usually these people have
something to say about their conquest to
make america white and take over and do
all that stuff they didn't have a sign
they didn't say hey could you send us an
email or send us a couple bucks or
here's our paypal address or just
absolutely nothing so i think this is
very possible if not likely rogan
obviously is asking the right questions
which is exactly what you're asking and
we should all be a bit more skeptical
these days i think we can at least agree
on that
and you know i enjoy a scholarly pursuit
and doing my research i actually read
the propublica piece that was cited in
the daily beast article and you know
they mention how this group passes
around a lot of propaganda they are
interested in intimidating uh people
but you know one of the guys i can't get
a member of the group had been arrested
for a gun charge but none of the things
mentioned in the article compared to the
destruction we saw across america's
cities and they also quote an anonymous
person using the name
samuel he's from new york apparently
here's what he said to propublica quote
i would say the biggest accomplishment
of masking up and obscuring our faces he
wrote we can make them feel as if there
are thousands of us when there are only
a few hundred and we could be anyone and
no one at the same time next time they
are at cvs and see a white kid with a
neat haircut it could be us
fear of the unknown is the greatest fear
of all
so
that's what they wanted to scare we
can't let them scare us
that's some fine journalism anonymous
samuel said it oh my god and it fits the
narrative that they would always want to
get out perfectly i can't believe it i'm
gonna have to really think about this
yeah so there we go with that but anyway
um you know and i and florida is doing
pretty well actually um
but don't listen to jimmy kimmel when it
comes to covid uh he was uh making fun
of ron desantis uh last night over the
way of course he's handled the whole
pandemic
i don't know where jimmy kimmel lives in
his little bubble in uh california but
here he is talking about florida
florida yesterday reported their first
case of omicron and omicron reported its
first case of florida so
rest assured governor omikron desantis
will do everything he can to make sure
as many floridians get infected as
possible you know
[Applause]
lowest transmission rate in the country
dave
yeah you know i i don't i personally
don't get my pandemic information from
people who have been in blackface like
jimmy kimmel or his ex-girlfriend sarah
silverman they're big blackface fans
that's just my thing about blackface and
pandemic information but let's even
pretend that jimmy kimmel believed this
thing was as deadly as he would love you
to believe would he be making jokes
about it would he be joking about all
the dead people in florida of course not
everyone knows right this is basically
complete nonsense at this point this is
endless scare tactics jimmy kimmel can
live in his 20 million dollar hollywood
hills mansion and he can wrap his head
in saran wrap and put on 87 masks but he
doesn't even do that because none of
these people live by their rules they
love gavin newsom who declared a state
of emergency or extended i should say
his state of emergency in california
about three weeks ago and then where did
he go he took a vacation in cabo uh it
was about 200 grand for the week for his
family believe it or not john you ever
spend 200 grand on a weekly vacation i'm
guessing not i know newsmax pays pretty
not yet dave
not yet i will someday i hope
and where's gavin newsom right now he's
in new york city on a book tour and he
sat with the shrieking harpies of the
view that's what a state of emergency
we're in here he's hocking a book that's
critical on the view
critical times
yeah uh
gavin newsom
what a gem gavin newsom if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification
bell